two three four
prepare to hear me play the bagpipes
perfectly okay
all right point proven
[Music]
that was we are the champions
[Music]
see amy fun thing about working cases
you meet people from all over the world
this song is a celebration song from
when a dog loses his fragility
who checks that
never been arrested before i mean i was
detained once by taylor swift's security
team but that was misunderstanding
she's probably gonna write a song about
me point is hater's gone hate shake it
off taylor swift always right
i'm telling you this machine is broken
ask me a question
is jay-z really your favorite artist yes
obviously
lie see it's busted is it
or is your favorite artist really taylor
swift no
lie all right fine she is
she makes me feel things she makes all
of us feel things
this binder tells the story of a sloppy
disorganized irresponsible
individual who's not allowed within 500
feet of taylor swift that was a
misunderstanding
come with me amy to the dumpster
me and amy going diving in the dumpster
so i
wake in the morning and
oh going on
we need a theme song the pontiac bandit
and jager cops oh
taking down crooks in the streets where
they live flooding with girls who are
hopping a bath
there's a talking police dog that helps
them solve crime the pontiac bandit and
jay got cops
with the wives cracking captain along
for the ride they'll have the pinchers
wherever they go
the talking dog flies in outer space
jokes on you they was always friends now
imma get my immunity
the ghost of the talking dog haunts the
precinct
the talking dog died oh man i know it's
a bummer note to end on
i wish you were alive dug today
god will give you a high five
this song is
thanks so much it's been a great
audience i mean it's a funeral that's
psychotic i'm so sorry
staring to the maggot draw i need to
step to her
step to her amy this isn't high school
musical yeah amy this isn't high school
musical too yeah and it isn't high
school musical three senior year
all right and mario is doing it with
theresa teresa is doing it with
paulie i knew that paulie is doing it
with
lisa and lisa's doing it with anthony
i really like this song did you come up
with a melody i'm pretty sure i did
freddie is cheating with bianca g
but also with her younger sister valerie
no oh yeah i saw them together that's
why it's in the song
we're good to drive in in a car
destination drug dealer's bar
pass the mic right over to charles we
forgot charles
but we can't turn back because we've
gone too far we have to turn back though
we can't leave them it was a good rhyme
though
all right but be careful oh don't worry
about me i'll be invisible
now you see me
[Music]
like when carly ray jepson puts out an
amazing single then you have to wait six
weeks for the album to come out
she's great i'm not apologizing it's
gonna be hard to spot a crazy person in
here they're all crazy tell me about it
this is more insane than the crowd at
the carly rae jepsen i mean slayer
concert
break my heart
say you love me again
you know what i like this song this hurt
that
shut up the nerve unbelievable
cried so many
your sores and string your bows the
beasts have gone away
and so on to the briefcase goes the
ground
didn't sing it with me i know accepting
teddy's jazz brunch invite was the only
way to get his phone back and save the
nine-nine but this place is literally
hell
eggman i [ __ ] in my lick eddie split
she's doing jazz about brunch
i'll skip his cup scoop this is super
uncomfortable
[Music]
jazz all right bob you want to play
hardball
good word on the street is you like jazz
i don't just like jazz i'm fond of it
i don't understand the difference tell
me where the file is right now or i will
ruin jazz for you forever i'd like to
see you try
wrong choice daddy-o ah
skipper scout got boob rapping jazz
jazzity jazz
juice old jazz jizz jang jingle jazz
well they stole their own books it's
plain to see but who's on the case the
addams family
terry is gomez i'm cousin it you are
wednesday let's do this
okay we should go so hey guys what's up
you want to join our acapella jam circle
oh no are you guys harry potter fans i
do not like where this is going three
four won't you come visit hogwarts
i'll be alone
this is actually pretty funny you got to
know harry potter one day i picked up my
battered old guitar and i
sang her a song oh how did it go oh
you don't want to hear it yes i do well
i don't have my guitar here
sing the song rosa rosa rosa rosa rosa
rosa rosa diaz diaz diaz diaz diaz
diaz diaz rosa diaz rosa diaz diaz
rosariza diaz diaz you are so cool
sounds better with a guitar cream in my
coffee and rock and roll
peralta what you're gonna do with all
that hunch all that hunch inside your
brain we're gonna source off solve this
case solve this case right in your face
we should probably leave this prison yep
so do you recognize any of these men i
was hiding in the bathroom stall so i
didn't see his face
but i heard him he was singing along to
the music at the bar do you remember
what he was singing i think it was that
song
i want it that way backstreet boys i'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to i want it that way really
okay you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one desire
number three believe when
i say number four i
wanted that
i never wanna
[Applause]
oh chills literal chills it was number
five
number five killed my brother oh my god
about that part
you